gianna runs jumps flies and whirls
through the world or the imaginary world
in the computer game jana sisters
twisted dreams
just like a quarter of a century ago
gianna has to fight through increasingly
difficult levels collecting diamonds and
battling evil monsters to save her
sister
the original version of this game now
belongs to the software studio black
forest games from offenborg
this new edition of giana sisters is
their first product
and it's already sold more than a
million copies
you see more and more old titles being
pulled out reworked and given a new look
and feel
developers have retained janna's
trademark double personality at the push
of a button she morphs from a lovable
girl into an alter ego with a punk look
and feel
that changes her abilities and her
surroundings
stefan schmitz was responsible for
adapting the old game into its modern
form he designed the individual levels
two things were really important for us
with john a sister's twisted dreams
first we wanted to stay true to the
original and the feelings it evoked
and we also wanted to use it to realize
our own interests and preferences
the original version of the game hit the
market in 1987.
but the german programmers were accused
by japanese company nintendo of
copyright infringement of its game super
mario brothers
the great gianna sisters was then taken
off the market
but pirated copies continued to sell
making the game something of a cult
favorite
original versions can be bought on the
internet for up to three and a half
thousand
euros it's no coincidence that the
offenburg studio hit upon jana sisters
for its first project
one of the programmers of the original
was a co-founder of black forest games
predecessor
back then the company had 70 employees
and plenty of success
with games such as airline tycoon and
desperados
but two years ago investors pulled out
and the firm went bust
a core team then acquired the rights to
jana sisters and founded black forest
games
the industry moves and changes so fast
that we were always aware we were taking
a big risk
but we also realized that this is what
we really want to do
the founders of the giana project began
a crowdfunding campaign on the internet
platform kickstarter and more than six
thousand private individuals and fans
invested some 135 000 euros in the game
for a studio like ours it's an
story the financing
and
important
maybe that was the case in the beginning
but now the funds you can get on
kickstarter have also dwindled
but it was great to test the interest in
such a computer game early on before
it's been developed it has the test
windows
and cooks so you can quickly see whether
your target audience is interested
in
some of the original staff were rehired
many could have made big money working
outside the computer games industry but
the programmers driven by their passion
stayed on and designed the game within
12 months
even chris hulsbeck the composer of the
original game is excited about his role
first of all i think it's great that i
could be part of this project because
the classic janus is this game was a
milestone of my career
are nine nationalities among the black
forest games employees many have become
good friends and they often cook
together at lunchtime
when we release jhana sisters the
company grew as
black forest games will take the
kickstarter route again on their next
project but for now the designers and
programmers are busy enjoying the
fantastic success of giana sister's
twisted dreams